hallo mein name ist luca und meine damen
und herren heute ist ein ganz ganz ganz
besonderer tag denn heute spiele ich zum
ersten mal seit jahren bald wieder mein
grab
er ist eigentlich gar nicht so eine
große neuigkeit ich habe in den letzten
wochen einfach unfassbar viele
kommentare unter meinen videos gelesen
von wegen von daher hab ich mir gedacht
hey hier stellen wir jetzt auch eine
neue welt in minecraft wir machen so ein
neues kleines minecraft projekt wo hier
selbst anhand der likes bestimmen könnt
ob eine nächste folge kommt oder nicht
von daher sage ich jetzt direkt zu
beginn des videos wenn ihr 60.000
laischaft unter diesem video also den
daumen hoch geben dann kommt direkt in
einigen tagen der zweite teil dieses
neuen minecraft projektes das ist
nämlich das prinzip wie ich mir das
ganze hier gedacht habe ich ja ich kann
tatsächlich auch manchmal denken ich
sage euch in jeder folge gegen eine
anzahl an likes die es schaffen sollte
oder irgend einen kommentar oder keine
ahnung was und wenn ihr das hinkriegt
zeigt es mir hey meine community die
lupe ist gewillt das eine ist apart
kommt und es besteht interesse nach
diesem projekt mittlerweile denke ich
jeder idiot verstanden worum es mir geht
und zwar weiß ich einfach nicht mehr auf
minecraft krass gut ankommen wird auf
meinem kanal vor allem weil das spiel ja
auch in den letzten monaten mehr und
mehr gefloppt ist also fordert ist halt
einfach durchweg das bekannteste und
beliebteste spiel gerade deswegen weiß
ich gar nicht ob es einen richtigen
markt sage ich mal für minecraft gibt
deswegen möchte ich war diese likes
einfach herausfinden hey wollt ihr dass
sich das projekt weitermache oder hat
das video 10 likes und kein interessiert
allerdings ist das ja heute unser erster
tag in minecraft mensch die sonne es
echt ziemlich hell
wir haben hier schon 15 holz das heißt
wir machen uns da raus erstmals eine
bank welt
ja
wie geht es jetzt nochmal weiter ich
glaube ich muss mal als nächstes so stix
majestix mit den sticks mache ich mir
jetzt erstmal eine spitzhacke der mit
[Musik]
618 automatisch zurück da rein ich weiß
noch als ich mein kräfte später bei hat
ganz anders immer mit der ruhe
jetzt ist unser ziel dass wir es erstmal
eine runde baden krass wie ich denke es
ist eigentlich eine gute idee
wir brauchen erstmal ein bisschen von
diesen bescheuerten kleinen steinchen
hier denn diese kleinen steine sind ein
bisschen besser als holz und mein gott
ich habe werkzeuge grundschule mir leid
langes stäbchen aber ich muss dich
wirklich leider töten denn die schafe
geben uns wolle und aus der wolle können
wir uns nachher ein bett machen und in
betten kann man schlafen und auch sex
haben aber das ist ein anderes thema wer
jetzt hier drei wolle das heißt wir
können unseren tempel wieder hinsetzen
und können uns jetzt hier aus einbeck
bauen und das bett können wir uns jetzt
hier hinstellen
wir können uns lieb at night und die
rings damen des turms laut mir ich kann
immer schlafen soll das baby fährt
cookie männer schreien ganz mysteriöse
also das hier ist jetzt unsere welt wir
haben auf jeden fall schon mal ein bett
das ist erstmal das aller aller
wichtigste wirklich zu beginn von
minecraft m dass man halt die nacht
überspringen kann
in der halb monster und skelette und so
bekommen wir sind unfassbar viele tiere
dicker sich aus die bauernhof oder war
es also so viele schafe und pferde und
was auch immer auf einem haufen und kühe
hier vorname auch noch das jetzt habe
ich wirklich selten gesehen ihr könnt
uns erst mal so ein bisschen umschauen
in unserer neuen welt und hier vorne
haben wir den ozean und pinke
schwimmende schwein eigentlich ist
dieser platz hier vorne finde ich schon
ganz schön um sich erstmal hinten oben
ein gott daher
der sehr brutale berge alter ego steht
ich weiß nicht ob ich komplett
bescheuert bin aber dass die bisschen
aus wie los angeles hierzu besonders
hinten somit den hollywood und beverly
hills und dann hier unten ist so wenn es
und somit dem strand ich bin glaube ich
echt bisschen dumm
ja ja ich sammle gerade ein bisschen
scheiße ein mit dieser scheiße baue ich
mir jetzt hier mein erstes haus nur
wenige minuten später
da das ist mein haus da kann man hier
reingehen da vorne geht schön die sonne
unter kann mir hier zu bauen und dann
können wir uns hier rein legen
ins bett
ein
dann ist der erste tag hier auch schon
vorbei mein rücken
guten morgen meine lieben freunde die
sonne geht hier schön aufscheint in
meine absolute traum villa rein an der
stelle würde ich den heutigen teil
minecraft mit luca jetzt auch beenden
wir haben ja keinen namen für dieses
projekt die wahrheit gesagt weil er die
berufsschule wenn ihr wollt dass
minecraft mit luca einem zweiten teil
bekommt weil ich meine ich bin eh der
beste mannschaft spieler und jeder will
eigentlich dass ich das weiterspielen
hast einen daumen hoch bei diesem video
da und bis 60.000 leicht kommt ein
zweiter teil
[Musik]
ein